venga estamos en el problema número 14 y
qué crees yo creo que en este vídeo
acabo este examen y esta sección así que
venga soy bastante animado el problema
número 14 que por cierto me dice
jaja seguramente estás pensando que
estoy muy serio pero la fx es igual a
equis cuadrada más bx
dónde y aquí viene lo importante
donde donde b y c son constantes
positivas ok si veces son constantes
positivas y tengo que fx es esta
expresión que tengo aquí lo que me
preguntan es cómo se ve la gráfica de fx
así que pues bueno hagamos un telo
cartesiano por aquí y me gusta que este
sea un viaje de la siesta ok y que este
sea mi eje de las x ahora lo primero que
quiero preguntarte es cómo sabemos qué
onda con esta expresión de fx de una
manera muy rápida tú me puedes decir que
es una ecuación cuadrática y por lo
tanto esta es una parábola esta de aquí
es una parábola ahora el dilema va a ser
saber si esta parábola abre hacia arriba
o hambre hacia abajo y dónde corta al
eje de las x de al eje de las guías pero
antes de pensar en eso quiero que te des
cuenta que es una parábola que abre
hacia arriba las palabras que abren
hacia arriba tienen un término positivo
un coeficiente positivo al lado de la
equis cuadrada en este caso al lado de
la equis cuadrada tenemos un signo más
un número uno y por lo tanto esta
parábola va a abrir hacia arriba esto
porque el coeficiente que está al lado
de la equis cuadrada vamos hablando así
es positivo ahora si el coeficiente que
estuviera al lado de la equis cuadrada
fuera negativo y déjenme recordarlo por
acá no está de más si el coeficiente de
la equis cuadrada fuera negativo
entonces sería una palabra que abriría
hacia abajo ahora como es positivo ya
sabemos al menos que abre hacia arriba
estamos en este caso de aquí lo segundo
que quiero que veas es que sé que es un
valor muy importante porque ese es el
valor en donde corta mi parábola al eje
de las 10 porque cuando llueva el dúo
efe de cero tienes efe de cero
bueno pues cuando x vale cero cuando x
es igual a cero que me queda pues
tendría cero 2 más b por 0 más sed y
este se va este se va antes solamente me
quedaría que f de 0 es igual a cero por
lo tanto ya sé dos cosas de esta
parábola la primera es que abre hacia
arriba y la segunda es que como se es
mayor que se lo está diciendo aquí como
se es mayor que cero entonces esta
parábola corta al eje de las íes en un
valor positivo supongamos aquí
supongamos que este elevador donde corta
a lejos las vías ahora sabemos que es
una parábola que abre hacia arriba pero
el dilema aquí es que hay varias
parábolas que abren hacia arriba y
además que pueden cortar por aquí el más
podría dibujar de algunas fíjate puedo
tener una parábola que más o menos paso
por aquí se abra paso por acá suba y
después pasó por acá se abra pasa por
acá y suba o puede tener
y podría tener una palabra que llegue
por acá llegué hasta este punto y suba
ok hoteles podría tener una parábola o
algo así que vaya que venga por acá pasa
por este punto después se habrá mucho y
después suba es a poder ser otro caso y
así se puede dibujar muchos muchos casos
cómo saber cuál de todos estos es
bueno para esto nosotros podemos
fijarnos en el valor de b&b es un número
positivo y lo que me dice es dónde está
indicado el vértice de mí para volar si
está en un valor positivo o el número
negativo en x etcétera pero para no
complicarnos más la vida vamos a ver si
ya con esta información es decir que
tengo una parábola que abra hacia arriba
y que además corta al eje las 10 en este
punto de aquí quiero ver si ya con esa
información puedo obtener la respuesta
mi inciso a tenemos una parábola que
abre hacia abajo por lo tanto no es la
respuesta una parábola que abre hacia
abajo no es la respuesta me ve también
abre hacia abajo por lo tanto no mi
respuesta se se intersecta al eje de
leyes en el origen pasó por aquí y eso
no es posible porque como se es positivo
como se es positivo entonces no puede
pasar en el origen debe de cortar al eje
leyes en un valor positivo algo más o
menos así de abre hacia abajo no en mi
respuesta y la única que se parece es el
psoe se parece a esta gráfica que tengo
aquí de color anaranjado inciso inciso y
se parece a esta gráfica que tengo aquí
y por lo tanto es mi única posibilidad
para responder esta pregunta así que no
nos hagamos más bolas pensando en be mi
respuesta es el inciso es perfecto ya
tengo un problema menos vamos al
siguiente borramos la pantalla el
siguiente problema es el problema número
15 y tengo
a un cubo gigante así que vamos a hacer
cubos por aquí déjame tomarme este verde
está verde me gustó ahora imagínate que
me tomo por aquí una cara de este cubo
tiene que ser un cuadrado así que
imagínate que esto es un cuadrado y
después vamos a dibujar los demás lados
aquí tengo a uno de estos lados ok
más o menos así ok por acá tengo otro de
estos lados ok
a algo más o menos así es algo como por
aquí después estos dos se unen ok a más
o menos según así creo que tú me lo
tienes un poco la idea si quieres alta
borramos de cachito y después tengo algo
más o menos por acá ok
después de estos dos también se ponen
algo más o menos así y para ayudar creo
que tú me entiendes el punto no es tan
importante que con mucho cuidado estemos
borrando y quitando todo esto pero estás
medias vamos a hacerlo déjeme borrar
esto de aquí no me sirve y deje el resto
de aquí para que no te confundas ok
puedo dibujar la parte de atrás de este
mismo cubo pero vamos a ver si ahorita
la ocupó a que otras cosas me dan me dan
un punto aquí un punto aquí que es el
punto
y me dan otro punto acá me da otro punto
acá que es el punto b y me dicen que la
arista o el lado de este cubo vale dos
unidades
por lo tanto a este lado vale dos
unidades esto equivale dos unidades
otros dos por acá otro dos por acá otros
dos por acá estamos repletos de dos en
este cubo ok después me dicen que a ive
cumplen que son el punto medio de esta
arista y de esta arista y si son el
punto medio eso quiere decir que la
distancia que hay aquí acá es uno y le
están se cree que acá también es uno
porque nosotros sabemos que cada una de
las aristas vale dos unidades y devuelve
nada para acá
esto vale uno y esto vale uno aunque yo
lo voy a poner así ahora lo que me
preguntan es cuál es la distancia que
hay de a ave lo que me preguntan es cuál
es esta distancia esta de aquí eso es lo
que yo quiero saber y bueno para
responder esto se me ocurre hacer un
doble teorema de pitágoras esto sale con
un doble teorema de pitágoras y para
entrar en calor antes déjame hacer la
parte esto tendría algo más o menos así
que después tendría algo más o menos así
para que te lo visualiza es mejor y
después tengo la parte de arriba tengo
algo así
así que y esto déjeme borrarlo a dónde
está la goma aquí está borremos todo
esto de aquí no me sirve no
me confunda ok a ver saquemos un poco de
conclusiones yo sé que esto se ve un
poco raro pero imagínate que yo tengo y
me tomo esta línea punteada de aquí me
voy a tomar esta línea de aquí de aquí
hasta acá
me tomo esta línea de aquí acá la
podemos calcular pues yo digo que sí
fíjate bien tengo en primer lugar antes
de usar esta herramienta es la parte de
aquí esta parte de aquí la voy a poner
aquí imagínate qué es esta parte de aquí
ok y después tengo esta otra parte de
ecuador salmón lo voy a poner de color
salmón tengo esta otra parte de aquí que
es un poco más larga de hecho es el
doble de larga que lo que es la parte
del anaranjado y después de nuestra
parte de rojo tengo esta parte de rojo y
déjame cambiar de herramienta tengo esto
de aquí quien por cierto es repitiendo
usado un tremendo rectángulo date cuenta
que aquí se forma un triángulo
rectángulo y por lo tanto vamos a
calcular su potencia pero qué datos me
dan bueno me dicen que este lado vale 1
es este lado de aquí esto vale 1 después
este lado vale 2 este lado vale 2 que es
justo este de aquí este sabemos que vale
2 porque es una arista y cuánto va a
valer la hipotenusa la hipotenusa va a
valer pues bueno es la raíz cuadrada la
raíz cuadrada
de este elevado al cuadrado de 1 elevado
al cuadrado más 2 elevado al cuadrado
que por cierto cuántos esto esto es lo
mismo que la raíz cuadrada de
415 la raíz cuadrada de 5 es decir que
la distancia que hay aquí acá y lo voy a
poner con rojo es la raíz de 5 y bueno
seguramente te estás preguntando por qué
es a que esta distancia que hay de que
acá esta distancia de rojo y las aquí
porque yo quiero que veas este siguiente
triángulo rectángulo me voy a tomar
ahora este esta parte de aquí de rojo
punteada este va a ser un ángulo de 90
grados porque estoy adentro del cubo y
ahora me voy a fijar también en esta
parte de aquí que por cierto la voy a
poner con color azul y en esta parte de
aquí es un color chillante perfecto que
me va a quedar pues tengo por aquí algo
así
es mi parte de azul ok después debo
planteado algo por acá tengo algo por
acá punteado el color rojo y después
tengo la distancia que yo quiero y
después tengo la distancia que yo quiero
que es ésta y acá de este color ahora
como la saco pues vamos a ver qué datos
verdad tengo que esta distancia que de
aquí a acá está que tengo de color azul
vale una unidad ahora déjame que verde
herramienta vale una unidad perfecto
ahora esta distancia de rojo para eso lo
calculamos esta distancia de rojo es lo
mismo que la raíz de 5 es justo lo que
sacamos aquí con lo que está escrito
aquí y yo lo que quiero sacar es la
distancia de aavv en esta distancia de
aquí a camps así que es la hipotenusa de
este triángulo rectángulo y por cierto
nosotros la podemos calcular como la
raíz cuadrada de quién bueno pues de un
cateto elevado al cuadrado de la raíz de
5 esto elevado al cuadrado más el otro
cateto elevado al cuadrado uno elevado
al cuadrado y cuando se ama usted lo
aquí en limpio yo tengo la raíz cuadrada
de que de la raíz de 5 elevado al
cuadrado
elevado al cuadrado pero la raíz de 5
elevado al cuadrado pues la raíz del
cuadrado se van y me quedaría simple
esencialmente
55 fíjate que estos dos se van se
eliminan la raíz cuadrada elevada al
cuadrado pues es el número que está aquí
adentro más el cuadrado de uno que es
uno ok ya tengo la raíz cuadrada de 5
más 1 que es la raíz cuadrada de 6 y
esta es mi respuesta la raíz cuadrada de
6 es la distancia que yo estaba buscando
esta distancia de aquí es la raíz
cuadrada de 6 que por cierto es mi
inciso de 1 ya no me cabe le voy a poner
aquí es preciso de y ya está ok este
problema estuvo bastante interesante y
lo recuerdo bastantes de nueva de
pitágoras pero creo que tampoco fue muy
difícil vamos a ver qué me dice mi
siguiente problema borramos la pantalla
espero que haya quedado claro el
ejercicio pasado
tú puedes resolver es el mismo ejercicio
en tu cuaderno e inclusive puedes ver el
vídeo cuantas veces quieras es uno padre
de tener todo este material en vídeo
aunque realmente creo que no estuvo tan
mal solución del problema número 15 y
este el problema en uno de los 16 es el
último problema de este examen y de esta
sección así que vamos a echarle muchas
ganas dicen si defino a x en cerrada la
definición de x en cerrada es lo mismo
que x cuadrada menos x
de esta forma defino axn cerrada paz y
me dice libro quien sabe por qué y por
otra parte me dicen que a encerrada a
encerrada en círculo es lo mismo que a
menos dos encerrada en círculo lo que me
preguntan es cuánto vale el valor de a y
creo que no es tan difícil estamos a
punto de acabar este examen
que hacemos ahora bueno primero no
edificar en encerrada en encerrada y lo
voy a aplicar la definición que tengo
aquí a encerrada por definición es a
cuadrada a cuadrada menos a lo único que
hice fue sustituir el valor de a en esta
función que tengo aquí
y esto por una parte ahora por otra
parte tengo esta expresión de aquí a
menos dos encerrada al menos dos
encerrada es lo mismo que sustituir en
lugar de x menos 2 es decir me va a
quedar a menos 2 al cuadrado menos a
menos 2 vamos a ponerlo a menos 2 esto
elevado al cuadrado que es lo que está
dentro en que se han cerrado menos a
menos 2 al menos 2 en lugar de x tengo
que poner al menos 2 y ya tengo una
ecuación cuadrática para de aquí podemos
despejar el valor de amd vamos a ver si
lo sale a tengo a cuadrada menos a esto
es igual y este de aquí este de aquí es
un binomio al cuadrado perfecto déjame
tomarlo con otro color este de aquí es
un binomio al cuadrado perfecto
vamos a desarrollar lo que me va a
quedar me dice es el cuadrado del
primero
del primero menos porque en este caso
tenemos el signo de menos si fuera más
sería más menos 2 veces el primero por
el segundo 2 por 2 por 2 4 y esto con
signo menos me va a quedar menos 4 a 4 a
2 veces el primero por el segundo ya
esto le tengo que sumar el cuadrado del
segundo que es dos más cuatro el
cuadrado de dos es cuatro y bueno
recuerda que si no te acuerdas de cómo
hacer esto de aquí recuerda que esto es
lo mismo que a menos 2 que multiplica a
a menos 2 pero bueno yo prefiero tomarlo
con las fórmulas del binomio cuadrado
perfecto ya esto a esto de aquí le tengo
que quitar a esta expresión de kim es
decir menos a menos 2 esto es lo mismo
que menos a más 2 estás de acuerdo - por
más menos menos por menos más ok y de
aquí tengo términos iguales por lo tanto
vamos a cancelar los este [ __ ] se va
con este [ __ ] y por otra parte este
[ __ ] se va con este [ __ ] entonces del
lado izquierdo
solamente 0 mientras que del lado
derecho me queda menos 4 a más 4
204 más 12 6 en todo lo que da 0 es
igual a menos 4 a las 6 y de aquí puedo
despejar en la nordea que te parece si
paso este 4 a del otro lado de esta
ecuación o dicho de otra manera sumó de
ambos lados de la ecuación 4a voy a
cambiar al color salmón que me gusta
tanto me va a quedar que 4a es igual a 6
ok sume 4 al de ambos lados de esta
ecuación y aquí voy a obtener que es lo
mismo que 6 entre 4 que por cierto esto
se puede simplificar se le sacó mitad a
arriba y le sacó también mi trabajo es
lo mismo que tres medios el valor de a
que me soluciona esta ecuación esta
expresión que tenía aquí que encerrada
sea igual a a menos 2 encerrada es el
valor de a de tres medios y ya le hice
este es la solución del último problema
del examen número 5 de la sección número
9 en el siguiente vídeo vamos a empezar
un nuevo examen hasta la próxima